[Music]
all right welcome to Hannity and
breaking tonight a major hurricane is
now barreling towards the Gulf Coast of
Florida and Tampa it is picking up steam
we're going to bring you live updates
throughout the night expected to hit
landfall tomorrow morning but first let
it let us all address the elephant in
the room shall we not the Republican
elephant well Joe Biden actually make it
to the Finish Line in 2024. now forget
about his typical four-day Work Week
forget about that's gone Biden is now on
track to barely work four days this
month and is headed back to the beach
again this weekend where he's struggling
to even move his beach chair needs more
rest and relaxation no doubt Joe Biden
is struggling physically and mentally
and is unable to handle the rigors of
what is the most important job in the
world even Democratic leftist
commentators are now acknowledging what
we've been telling you for over three
years we'll play that in a minute but
there's also another reason that Biden
flees Washington D.C every chance he
gets tonight it's obvious the president
is simply not capable of answering any
real concerns about his very real
bribery money laundering allegation
Scandal and that is getting worse by the
day this week in response of a foia
request the National Archives and record
Administration confirmed that it was in
possession of nearly five thousand four
hundred documents emails other
Communications featuring one of Joe
Biden's pseudonyms that he'll utilized
to conduct official business as vice
president now move over Pierre delecto
and Carlos Danger because there are
three new pseudonyms in town it is now
believed that Joe Biden used the names
Robert L Peters Robin Ware and jrb Ware
to obscure his Communications and kind
of in the meantime skirt records
requests including Official White House
emails about Ukraine that were
reportedly now sent to Hunter Biden hmm
just before his trip where he leveraged
a billion dollars that's what we're
hearing now why on Earth would Hunter a
private citizen be included on official
government emails about Ukraine now
could it possibly have something to do
with Hunter's cushy job that paid him a
fortune on the board of the Ukrainian
oil and gas giant a corrupt company that
was paying an admitted drug addict at
the time millions of dollars despite the
addict's risky lifestyle and absolutely
no experience an energy oil gas or the
country of Ukraine coincidentally it is
the same company that his pops Joe Biden
or Robin wear if you prefer protected by
forcing Ukraine to fire that country's
prosecutor General who was investigating
Barista for corruption now five days
after he talked to his son and barisma
Executives they were begging for D.C
help Hunter couldn't provide that they
wanted to get rid of the prosecutor they
wanted that process executor off their
back Joe delivered five days later and
Hunter continued to get paid and the
Biden family to continue to be enriched
now nine bidens according to James Comer
the house oversight committee all paid
through those many many show
corporations including grandchildren I
wonder what they did for barisma now if
this was just all one big coincidence
well why was Hunter Biden ever copied on
government emails about Ukraine and
maybe drafts of the speech that his
father was going to give the Ukrainian
Parliament five days after he called his
dad with the Barista Executives why did
Joe Biden use a synonym for those emails
now if he truly had nothing to hide why
did Biden lie to us why why did he lie
to you and the American people as a
candidate as a president over and over
and over again about his involvement
with his son's sketchy business hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else